well I am here to wish you a very happy
dennee Christmas yes I'm here on the
very very popular Jim Martin Sam Roberts
show to wish you a holly jolly Christmas
yeah did you [ __ ] it up
no I do but I started talking I was
potting his music up my daddy's gonna
start talking oh this music but it's
Mike wasn't on at first
well they the half a second jump oh no I
don't really wait until it stops and
then I turn over is my time oh I don't
think Dennis talking in front of a deal
then you talk the second others you play
for a second no I understand that's why
I didn't want to turn to my Tom before
you like the intro is playing cuz then
if you talk if you think you're off mic
you let the Christmas music establish a
little bit yeah and then you start then
jump in there he did jump to Nicole's
welcome to the Christmas special holiday
special that's true we can't just say
Christmas because we have a feeling
we've invited rich boss to help us put
the Christ back in Christmas take the
nails out of his hand
welcome rich boss and now we guess he'll
be here at some point
yeah I'm sure and another guest will be
here at another point bit more than one
mark Normand just I forgot mark sorry
yeah Anthony - yeah Anthony cou Mia Troy
Quan is here the Travis dog is here oh
and of course or wasn't that's all right
it's a lot of buttons have you guys ever
tried to get cousin Brucie to come in
here and answer I'm doing it just on
email I'm a big fan of him bow bow
the icon Falcon for phallus yeah I got
the gifts have already started the gift
exchange has already begun here and yes
in this very festive show yes thank you
very much
there's always one right there's always
one staffer that gives gifts and we're
like you you have to give us
yeah it's good in science what is it a
gift part I don't know it's a little
Visa card but give me money to bank
cards anything you guys don't want I'll
take there it is mine wasn't actually in
the was assigned no no but the terms are
here so that's good the terms reported I
don't know is for it's a visa TD Bank
gift card which is very very thought
very thoughtful and it's a gift for me
it says it's just for you oh yeah for
you so I thank you but I don't know
there's I'm assuming therefore 500
there's no to from value or message on
here no Merry Christmas no happy
holidays
thanks for everything this year you're
just here you just just so we know who
is it did you get one Troy yeah yeah I I
was in a gym lottery takes the other day
and they have it he's not play a lot of
no they weren't for me sure they have
happy holiday cards that you put a lot
you know greeny quarter I got four of
them I can give out Christmas cards
happy holidays it doesn't say lotto just
as happy holiday perfect yes you should
that's a really warm feeling to get one
of those who wouldn't want one of those
on the holidays sometimes I've I've
gotten birthday cards to me and I just
cross him out and put happy man what's
out my name like that no instead of
instead of a picture of the Voss family
you get a New York State lot of gift
cards Christmas cards I I get my [ __ ]
I got my parents sent me one and my you
know a family we do like a Bob Simon I
don't get a whole lot I used to I I
guess we're starting to get more and
more now but that's like I guess as your
friends start having families they start
feeling like that's something they
should be doing I don't know if we did
I've never sent one with my kid are you
doing one with your you kid with little
Edgar I don't know I I think we took
photos but I don't know if Jess made
Christmas cards or not do do if we did
if anybody out there is family friends
and did get a Christmas card from the
Roberts just no I didn't even know if we
had it you know it would be funny if you
took if you did the Christmas card
you're holding him and the card cuts off
it cuts his head so you can't see his
face
this is Pete he's a private person you
ever do your Christmas cards with the
kids on your stomach I've never done I
want to do them I feel bad like but I
last year I sent one back to Baba
I didn't I didn't this year I may be
great if you did if you did like lonely
guy Christmas cards like you did you
went to one of those places where
families go for a Christmas photo by
myself you were just there by yourself
in a sweater I just but just a loan and
plenty of room in the photo right not
crop yeah yeah that cropped clothes just
so you knew that there was lots of room
and nobody was there I should get them
from someone's family who's divorced now
but I have them when they were family so
it's you know it's a rare one it's a
collector's item some of them are nice
that this tangles always have very funny
ones I was about to say I don't think
I've gotten this tangled card this yeah
having the Justin and Eric I'd better
not have written me off the [ __ ] list
I will burn your homes down I didn't get
one so I I feel like I wouldn't be
written off the list I don't think I
would have been I don't think so either
but so yeah we have a couple of I guess
little things for the maybe uh Truffaut
I got this uh I just wonder how much is
for it I thought this is soulless gift
from it's from its from man it's very
nice and I told him how much I
appreciate it but it is like it is still
there's no there's no soul at all in it
it's emotionless I mean yeah I gladly
would give we should give each other
gifts and then one year he goes oh I
forgot yours is in my car and he never
gave it to me I can't say hey I never
give you a problem sure I had it for you
in the car but you can't remember that
give us long time you say $700 gift
right and then I went to hey I want to
go take his Yeezys then he gave me to
the store that you know last time boss
was here you gave him the easies because
Norton had bought a whole bunch of
Yeezys to wear on his special and we had
one here right so there's no place rich
we gave it to rich because I wasn't
gonna sell them you just don't know the
culture yeah I said I don't know II
probably six
104 sir rich is gonna sell them and look
good money yes put the money because
they aren't there like something that
they're not new these are one of the
originals they're probably go for like
six hundred sixty second I bought him in
a store mmm-hmm I took him out of the
box the guy looked at it for one second
one fakes but why did you have them I do
I did wear them on my special I have it
I bought a bunch of sizes they cost me
some I mean it was twenty bucks a piece
of paper you owe me an hour
no we're like really big because I don't
know anything about those sneakers like
if they were Irish but there's little
things you might know like the bike the
bucket the box there's nothing on them I
know I was not it's a cardboard box with
tape on it was held together with duct
tape on oh you did I I thought maybe you
bought a bunch of pairs just do them in
a bow okay did it did it worry you at
all that there was a Asian writing
written on the car and I didn't even see
that
this isn't even a shoebox and no I don't
he didn't put it in the box
yeah he said these are fake and medium
from maybe 10 feet between us he knew oh
he could tell and I almost said oh yeah
well you're good I just say you're lying
he's famous and I was gonna call you to
get you on the phone but you know I wish
you would listen to this you can hear it
like wicking and stuff well you're gonna
get me on the phone
yeah I didn't you got you did you get
indignant keine I did argue because it
wasn't mine I didn't give up [ __ ] the
only thing that bothered me was that I
drove to New Brunswick
I was wrestler golf that day right
by you know it's not too it wasn't too
many warm days now I still made it out
to play good at one o'clock instead of
at 11:30 right and but I had to drive to
New Brunswick which is like 25 minutes
from my house it's an employment yeah
yeah you can see the glue here by the
way where the so I don't know anything I
can see the glue I didn't inspect the
sneakers right I just put that in there
I don't know those sneakers I never
bought it he did he did it's not even
one part it's the entire side of the
shoe you can see the glue that connects
there's a bad sign on a show yeah that's
that's poor quality what size a day
that's probably seven they might fit you
Denny
you want to try them on you want to rock
some [ __ ] Nazis yeah some feces what
these feces sure don't fit him did you
feel silly like so at no point did you
realize I turned around and walked out
quick
you did what frauds in my hand Jim and I
we've been giggling for two weeks yeah
oh yeah we say on the air but when we
gave you the shoes that day in studio
like both of us had to avoid eye contact
with you and with each other because
neither one of us could keep a straight
face a lot because we knew how fake they
were if they were if they were ones or
eleven so I would have seen her right
away
sure I've never seen a pair of those you
know feces yes pinkies I am on - hey
what happened is it did you turn down
the tunes oh yeah okay no no I just
didn't want you guys really pulled one
over on me I'll tell you that we did yes
we can shoe store 25 oh yeah and you
actually went up to a shoe store and
said excuse me sir I'd like to sell me
they don't buy real sure not only I
Drive there I don't we finish out front
for the store to open course there were
and I'm standing out there in new bunch
of with a bunch of thugs and I'm we're
wearing real sneakers and you worried do
yourself a man I hope nobody Rob's me
for these very valuable sneak wear and
all that
where are new if you had got your Rolex
stolen would that make you happy if he
had his tooth knocked out as well
ecstatic to Titan wait hold on what did
you say it's insured yeah yeah what does
that mean you started would add to the
human side I have insurance
let me tell you how dumb and stupid my
wife is remember when I did you know the
shoes were fake no she goes what are you
doing I said I'm selling me an order to
respect the money and I love that like
willing to go to all this trouble to
split the money on those sneakers and
then he still finds out their face do
you know how hard it was there Fugazi
day what so after after the show that
day rich comes into the office Oh No
and he doesn't have the box oh you're
right and I said rich where are your
shoes and you've never seen someone run
back to the back so fast and then he
comes back because I oh I almost Oh Jim
hundreds of dollars if Richard lost the
shoes and said look I want to pay you
for them would you have let him yep we
were gonna get six hundred minimum right
so I'll take 250 or 300 I would take it
to fifty drop in the bucket nice I left
him in the bathroom I'm sure nobody
grabbed him they didn't see this
anonymous cardboard box with tape on an
Asian writing why wouldn't it open what
about this packing tape yeah the packing
tape was already it's not is the packing
tape really baby you know no they're
playing tapes actually it's it's ripped
here that's very yellowed there's kanye
west's known for being a high fashion
riot sort of I clash and he's been a
fashionista he would not approve this no
he was not
I just thought it was a boxing Homer I
thought he bought like eight pairs and
they
so are you gonna say rich about the you
were to say by the insurance then you
and all ain't dumb your wife is yeah why
she stupid so Jim the other night I go
yeah we got to by the way you can get
the shoes that gym shoes are modeled off
of for sixteen hundred dollars off goat
goat is an app and they're going for
sixteen hundred
yeah damn I would have taken six so
she's uh so I saw Jim the other night I
go yeah we're going to to Christmas
parties one out of Governors and and the
scan had their Christmas party
what was it Monday night Monday night
and so I did Anthony and then Bonnie was
driving in and picked me up so now we're
driving
we're gonna go to governor's get there
nine from nine to ten drive back and go
to the stem from like eleven to one so
we're driving out to Long Island on the
Li E which is a [ __ ] night it's
literally the worst road in the country
it's neither the night our ninety five
cross process it's [ __ ] horrible
all of them Bell part another state
digits photo mark way right cuz you went
around four hundred neck yeah it back to
you rich anyhow have you really please
anybody see that no I've had that in the
my Pat my pocket since 1994 Parkway
there's something here so we're driving
out to Long Island bumper-to-bumper and
now we're about 20 minutes away I go uh
make sure tonight's the party she goes
to her [ __ ] email it's in January I
could not be happier that's I won a they
laugh I was laughing cuz I was so mad
that she's so stupid and she's filming
me telling her how stupid she is why did
she think it was yesterday Monday or
might you think it was Monday I don't
know she just look what I think what
would have told me that she had shitty
decision-making that there couldn't be a
worse road to be on and find out you're
[ __ ] nothing god I wish you were too
showed up but it was just joy Cola doing
a set
me at war here early then she bought a
box you know for the owner because we go
to pay our respect you know I didn't say
that by the way I almost spit on him why
I he goes even go to the Christmas party
I'm like no I like I like those guys at
governor's a lot but I work it's hard on
a Monday it's all the way out yeah you
know if I was off that I stay sure but
it is inversed cuz I'm just going to pay
my respect I think my guys are a crime
family or you community like The
Sopranos respect to them pay you risky
exactly you know I pay my respect if I
do this show I try to do a good show we
chat yeah hey thanks that's it yeah he
is a good guy though well I'm sure
boulders it's it's it are you gonna pay
he reminds me of what a club owner must
have been like in 1967 like you know
those guys they like club yeah hey how
are ya for you for you but yeah he
treats you great he should what yeah
that's why you gotta go pay your
respects
hey this respect not respects oh why
can't we go back and just replay these
things I have no idea we gonna fix it or
not it's not a it's not a fixing issue
we're supposed to move over to a
different type of system so we just left
the system it didn't move over to the
new system yeah that's cool what's
what's going on I would love to hear
that do away with the old one before
you're ready for the new one yeah I see
god damn it
who's this card from I don't know if we
gonna because we have Anthony come here
coming in whenever Anthony arrives he's
a course allowed to arrive when he wants
is he is not a paid employee he's a
guest yes yes just swinging by today the
old Christmas shindig and now where is
Travis uh where's Travis is there no I
ain't the one he's got the dogs and
everything oh it's cool beard in the
camera oh hi um where's that Anthony
he's right here
yeah yeah I would like to thank him he's
on his way in
okay those shoes don't fit your head
Danny no there's too small oh wow
[ __ ] Danny's all first to keep coming
in there would fit him probably you were
shocked when you find
for not legitimate because we did not
really see no sneaker so you didn't had
I thought he got ripped off now that you
know that he was just that we were
giving you a hard time we're trying to
make you look like a fool I'm a nine and
a half what get the other kid what if
you wear with little Rob where I have to
assume a nine
I bet rob them no but you don't see it
shoes in the morning you don't see the
song I see shoes I don't know what yes
have you ever worshipped his feet no
surprisingly Thank You Anthony this was
very thoughtful actually a $25 gift card
thank you very much you didn't have to
give us money you really didn't have to
give you don't have to give the ER it's
just a little something that's very nice
did you sign it right to do that
I completely forgot am I also I put my
card back in but my thing it was just
loose there wasn't like you know there's
a hard to put in no they're not they're
super easy so you just struggling
nothing would make me happier after you
give me those you guys fire him those
sneakers they're not yours they're not
yours they goof yeah mine the last one
you should try to sell them on eBay like
try to scam somebody and actually make
some money off of them oh why don't I
start a criminal business you've been
doing that for 30 years hey close hey
they'll fit him you're gonna put them on
put on the feces smaller than seven I
hate to I hate to throw the card out
though no yeah I don't want to either I
almost don't want to spend the $25 gift
card because I don't want to take it out
of the sentiment oh I know I'm gonna
mount this yeah
in my home I only have one Christmas
card bounded just to remind me of like
the impact that I made on my staff this
year yeah I didn't get my parents warned
you I probably come soon I didn't get my
mother or anything no no they didn't
said I never get Christmas cards
Hobbs displayed bow yeah it's probably
why appreciate that very much anything
thank you very much how come you didn't
write on them I just I thought the guy
was gonna write like $25 and everything
and then I was gonna sign it but even
write anything and I just completely
forgot oh okay
look I'm 90 I'm not one to look a gift
horse in the mouth you know thank you
very much anything you get done with
anything do you told me not to get him
anything he like what's he gonna say
yeah well who's the boss he has to say
that I told you that in advance
yeah well cuz I was like what the only
time anybody ever says in advance hey
don't you get me anything
least a little something yeah I was
gonna get him the same thing but he was
like if you get me anything you know
please don't get please don't get me did
you get up anything
who well now that ain't now that we've
gotten our gift from Anthony I guess we
can bring Rob back in so that he can
give us his gift right
yeah oh yeah we nice bring him in bring
Robin to give awesome to give us the
gift card from him thank you rob right
right I listen I mean that's the
appropriate thing yeah are you taking
the staff out like you and Jim taking
the staff we can't today
hold on we would we would we know the
answer no we're gonna do something in
the new year definitely yeah yeah yeah
Jan party Jan a couple of gift cards for
the boys no I didn't bring anything what
I didn't know I'm sorry guys but we're
like I know I were your superiors you're
supposed to shower as we hi I didn't I
felt yeah I didn't want to feel
pressured I didn't know what to get I
didn't want to get just gift cards like
you come from such a better family than
him yeah you would that you would know
to do yeah one is the one is a well
schooled boy one is rough and tumble
right collared shirt under the hoodie
yes yeah yeah yeah able for work not so
much no not at all no no no but who
brings in the gift card he break this
right it's the boy who went to the
school of hard knocks that's right
treat present our gifts to the boys we
should yeah everybody all right no I'll
go first
everybody
your eyes wait now what today do these
because these come with them or these
come separately
well you rob sighs are open shut your
eyes I'm trying to give them their gifts
oh yeah
so I know you guys have worked really
hard yes you have and you know serious
doesn't always pay they don't always
help out at the end so this this should
help you guys here you go and wait your
eyes have to remain closed there you go
and we have to I want to be you have
something for them I do but I'll hand it
to Sam to hand to you okay all right and
and by the way throwing Travis just so
you guys know little some I suppose boys
done that I don't you know don't get too
excited Troy don't spoil it for the boys
one for these and I got Travis is here
eyes closed boys they're afraid we're
gonna do that's right you cannot that's
very very nice and oh all right
everybody open your eye happy holidays
what'd you guys get I am wait hold on a
sec is Travis didn't get hit all right
yeah they bring his injury in the
trailer hole again I got this one for
the Travis dog okay okay okay no peeking
Trey come on Travis so much I really
appreciate this is a major good boys
yeah here comes Sam possibly the best
Christmas ever
[Music]
[Music]
no pinkies Travis pinkies that's what
she said as she got into the car tied
down the hatch sorry two papers to tape
together a knots and pin to my number
one fans ship black-and-white printed to
my fan number one you know this is great
because I didn't have either of these
things plate see this for a second this
one it looks like chip might have used
some scrap paper because there is there
are websites on the top yeah like a link
on the bottom I like how it's folded
folded and Anthony yours was folded but
it's also papers from August it's off
center oh you know there's a large and
he signed with black on black writing
yeah black on a black and white my fan
chilling crime chip Troy did you do you
like the gifts yeah
he's speechless yeah Congrats everybody
Danny I forgot I we should we didn't I
just realize yeah that's that's why I
feel silly but I won by a frame now yeah
yeah Travis you have to buy a weird size
frame that's fine or you know I could
just cut it to size oh you can do that
with that my then it'll lose its value
yeah yeah Travis's photos printed across
two sheets of paper and taped together
there's a website he was on Jim's
printer then I was from Jim's good boy
computer one Anthony must move
yeah let's see you know the other one
may well look we're saloon blue it
you missed the presentation yes you
missed the gift already yeah he's not to
look for the eats look wow look what the
staff got yeah my goodness hey signed
chip chipper center of chip-chip Orson
and and I'm not saying pin oh wow I
don't know which one is better yeah well
lucky this is a really special good look
for Anthony Wow look at that
me and fresh out of pins I'm sorry
that's why did I actually think from
that picture that it was like a eight by
ten glossy or something it's literally
printed out it's been used for something
else Anthony's on one or two pieces of
paper hey this is on an Anthony's been
fired memo from where hi rich radio man
it's crazy yeah well nice thank you chip
looks cool in this yeah it's a good shot
a cig he in his mouth
yeah a hundred-acre the chip didn't have
a color printer huh just black and white
well he did more economical but there a
lot of black ink on this one that is
wasteful that was wasteful yeah but the
same thing would have happened if it was
in color the black would have been a
well of course yeah sure um sorry doing
man
good good is it hard getting up twice in
the same week early no no yadus it's
terrible there's no no I take my naps is
what I do from doing morning radio here
for so long over the course of the years
I was able to just you know crap on it
no no did you go home or do you stay in
the city stay in the city stay at the
apartment the the other night I was at
the Friars Club roast trying to find
targets yeah I was I was over there
having a little meeting about compound
media of course and I go back to my
apartment it was
probably somewhere around there to to a
and then at at 4:00 a.m. where I usually
would have gone to the karaoke bar some
guy shot and killed right outside the
karaoke bar that I go to tonic Wow
Street actually yesterday morning was
closed yeah when we came to I was like
50th Street or something in that area
yes like 49th 48:48 joint yeah right
next to the strip joint right I think
the area of course you know Denny knows
yes the strip joint yes next to the gay
club okay so they got shot and killed
right outside
let me guess yeah yeah right now Wow
karaoke bar it was I guess some argument
between two gentlemen outside on the
sidewalk we melted in somebody getting
their head you never know who you're
[ __ ] arguing with like I never know
you got to like you got a sense to just
walk away sometimes yeah that's really a
rage yeah yeah do they find out who did
it no but please you know I think
they'll find out who did it
probably yeah it's usually guys that
knew each other that's good yeah yeah
yeah than that my PD is pretty young but
it wasn't the karaoke bar that's
smelling what is right in front of it
yeah why is that from your place
not a couple of blocks yeah yeah Pupkin
the Jerry Langford building over there
oh yeah same apartment right yeah yeah
how long you had that place probably six
years now it helps yeah it's so much
better than the commute right pumping
out to Long Island and you know it's
sometimes I'll be there like I've been
there the entire week you know no wow
and a B&B it when you're not there
that's what I do yeah
air B&B you ever air B&B your place
never
and then in good conscience go and sleep
in the bed and god knows what those
slobs are doing in there never father of
three that's right
after holiday party with it oh they were
at tonic well it's 4 a.m.
hanging out with colleagues from Harlem
Buffalo Wild Wings restaurant they were
investigating they said it was an
arguing with a woman who was outside the
bar with two men one of the men pushed
him in the other ones job so he's
arguing with this woman she's with two
guys one pushes everyone shoots him I'm
what the [ __ ] is doing with that one of
the two men were wearing a black
skullcap and black jacket he was still
being sought late Tuesday mm-hmm but I
mean like just literally you're out
there for um you're having a dumb
argument with some lady and one guy now
you get shot now no so one of the guys
would the lady as a spouse and the other
guy I don't know what their relationship
was by the way as we're saying this
three kids my Siri just turned on it was
like just quoting everything I just said
how many people have gotten [ __ ]
I have debated talked about this before
yeah when you're in a text message with
your wife or your girlfriend and you
don't send and not realize you can just
keep talking like you've been in the cab
and you're like okay listen I'm gonna
come back make a left here please and
then it shows up Oh how many people have
[ __ ] up like that Siri says you're
always talking yeah yeah that's a
frightening you know it's an argument
all the sudden you that's why I [ __ ]
steer clear of any arguments in Times
Square I would never you ever know it
again you don't know what this guy was
fault it was I would say whoever no one
deserves to get their head [ __ ] split
open is your yeah as you're just leaving
a bar yeah maybe a little drunk some
[ __ ] they thought they had some woman
out there on the sidewalks getting a
little lippy sure but they were wearing
a Buffalo Wild Wings they're having
their big party fun everything is going
right really I guarantee that ruin the
party they were singing some karaoke
probably
the girl was probably with a dude got
lippy with another dude and the dude
shot the other dude I'm saying dude bye
dude bro imagine he was up there right
before he left
doing karaoke just going hit me with
your best shot
and then ironically enough somebody
decides someone did [ __ ] that guy check
to the heart and yo - you know and then
BAM you shot bitter bitter irony Sam
it's true except you were shot in the
head not in the heart it would be a
little more ironic but still some irony
Sheriff
I shot the sheriff probably or yeah his
nickname was Sheriff any other guys what
are the chances of that show zero even
if your name is Buford T justice this
just makes sense when you're going out
of your mouth no no probably not you go
to a park of Earth and you go yeah I'm
going out to pay my respect don't
respect respect right party ever say I'm
gonna pay my respects I don't think I
ever say that no-one's ever unless it's
like a wake unless it's a dumbbell
watching a band mob movie and trying to
sell it he didn't no no no one says that
our business pay my respect gonna go pay
my respect and it's my said no you said
respect when you corrected me when I
said matter yes have a call you don't
have a thing you can't prove it it's
broken you follow that one Troy playback
is broke right no you're right you're
right I wish it wasn't
cuz boss has already made a few blunders
morning one wonder horrible bomb -
really yeah oh my god wasn't that
Sheriff no no that was the follow-up
that was the staying alive Saturday
Night Fever you missed the other one was
really bad yeah we had boss cheer about
the shoes no we pack a lot into the
first a palace certainly fun-filled sign
that we gave boss knowingly we gave him
a pair of bootleg Yeezys that we're
really really hoping honey dollars I
paid for really face really fake do you
buy more than one pair the fake ones yes
I bought likes for pair shadow I was
warm I wore fake Easy's on my last
special so I didn't know what size would
fit so I bought like six of them from
this website it's Chinese writing from
here so boss actually took them home and
brought them to a sneaker store a new
brunch I told me like 600 we'd split it
oh my god and what did the guy say just
saying I do my tea box you want fake
that's what you do they buy and sell
sneakers but vos argued a little bit
like no I don't think so
I did wrong mrs. celebrity do the ones
have labels on it that's say the brand
of the sneaker and no real size there's
nothing in this I didn't look I just
didn't pay attention there was now oh
well yeah big deal you know you learned
that's true you do you've done one and
not the other I wish you aren't doing
one oh yeah I left my phone at home
today oh no and it's been it's been I'm
enjoying it right no you're not oh no I
feel out of sorts
isn't that [ __ ] it's not [ __ ]
when people go you know I left my phone
at home I couldn't be happier I wouldn't
go that far but I put on ik eye today
like I realized like five minutes after
I left the house that I didn't bring to
take the phone out of the charger and I
went you know what [ __ ] it
yeah and I drove in I turned on the the
traffic report on the radio and then and
then I changed my route based on what
they were reporting it wasn't no GPS no
not do you know what I am he's a man
slow down
yeah when I was going to Australia I've
said I flew Qantas
which was just [ __ ] the worst and I
they have no [ __ ] Wi-Fi in this [ __ ]
airline and I'm in the middle and the
Amika where's the wife I was like we
don't have it yet
maybe next I'm like what do you mean you
don't have it yet and the guy says and
the guy goes well you know if you're the
businessman you want to get away from
the email I'm like is that how they tell
you to spin this and then I literally
almost [ __ ] had an air rage incidents
all man you really think that that's how
you - all right you're right no
businessman emails shut up
yeah I might not want to get things done
while I'm traveling halfway around the
world
yeah we don't we get it next year oh
thanks perfect Qantas was the worst was
it wow that's surprising I always
thought it was a good airline they were
awful you know enjoy a little bit like
no I on a plane no if I don't have to
buy if I don't want it if I don't want
it I don't get it right now what are you
Grizzly Adams now China [ __ ] just get
em at all you know the Bears own
revenant was it yeah Grizzly Adams bear
I don't know no gentle Ben I used to cry
they said when gentleman and my mother
said whatever gentle thing whenever
gentle Ben was over I would cry oh oh I
never saw the program no you referring
to big bad it was a little better than
when ruff Bob came over the music for
gentle Penn the bear show I don't
remember what it was but it was about a
famous Clint Howard Clint Howard it was
Ron Howard's bro yeah his little brother
was on the gentle Bend never took off
like Andy Griffith no it
wait wizard you know I you this is all
Wow music do they show the opening at
all or now and I see the opening with
gentle Ben was to the boy but the best
part is the boy leaning against the bear
and that bear in that picture has a
[ __ ] chain around its neck of course
you're gonna cry when this is over
Dennis Weaver was the father it's
swimming time that was go to the pool
Dennis Weaver oh my how [ __ ] old
school is this oh look at the bear cubs
[Music]
watching and oh it was great
did you like flipper you know I I'm sure
I did and of course lassie but gentle
Ben was my guy flip yeah that was going
I do remember BJ the BJ in the bear yeah
it was you did you watch a BJ McKay and
this is do you member the son PJ in the
bear no I didn't watch that yeah Jim
Greg evigan in a chimp he was a truck
drivers right and he his buddy was a
little chimp and it would drive around
yeah be trainers was a tease it was a
tease here it is No
cheese oh the chimps driving the truck a
chimp is driving the truck I know I'd be
using the horn that doesn't seem right
I love this Shoto I like it it's a tease
so will you go ahead a little bit wrong
Rick what decided him it wasn't lost on
me I liked it yeah they needed words to
the songs in the 80s yeah and the 60s
like that with the gentle Bennett stuff
of music was fine enough by the way
coming back a little bit what's
happening right here no no just says
watch he's dragged a vegan sleep-driving
look he's looking out the window having
a conversation who's he talking to right
here watch maybe beat yeah what's
driving wait look
let me know this corner no no no see
he's driving leaning out the window
talking out the window like a truck
driver would talk to maybe a pretty seat
cover out there yeah hot shot beaver
maybe he's on a beaver hunt out there
because what about the Smokies up there
and he's got a chimp what not the cutest
little guy what a horrible life for the
monkey being taken on the [ __ ] Road
in a truck I was a truck with a hat in
his little coveralls what a horrible
[ __ ] thing for the trucker you got
nothing with those two little fans and
you got this [ __ ] primate [ __ ] doesn't
seem like he's wearing rich boss's hat
everyone wanted a pet monkey yes you
watch The Little Rascals Claude Akins
yeah you'd watch like the law Rascals
and stop and spank he would have the
monkey and it would just look like a fun
thing to have if you're a kid a little
monkey
yeah flood ref will stress him out like
flipper flipper was stupid because you
had to be in the [ __ ] water yeah
that's great but gentle banker coming to
the house yeah now the Greg evigan x'
monkey could get leave the truck and do
that it's like oh let's play with
flipper yeah I don't feel like it wet
today yeah put a hook in flippers mouth
and bring me the living room and watch
him suffocate
throw the
hunting a tub how about my mother - car
that's an old one van Dijk Jerry Van
Dyke my mother the car oh this was
flipper if your mother was a car she
should have had her garage aborted they
should have put a hanger in her garage
it's pulled out that this isn't the
theme horn was very whimsical to a
flipper very whimsical you know you know
he's in the flipper movie Oh
Michael Madsen right Oh oh yeah when he
goes hey flipper always trying to be
good-natured and if she doesn't work
yeah he's trying to be dad Michael
Madsen doesn't he go in and he [ __ ]
cuts flippers fin off that's right sings
into it did not know chip was what's
that for my three sons no not that chip
no he's yeah is this the song yes it's
terrible yeah sucks what a dud flipper
was a dive Johnny works yeah exactly
it was all like these kids befriending
animals shows we're like a big thing
back then this was bunk
they had one in Australia called Skippy
Skippy the bush kangaroo what and that
was a that was a show also where the
kids would be playing with Skippy a
kangaroo I don't know it was on TV here
back and let me get the theme for the
scenes none of your beeswax there it is
that's great is this where the kid goes
to pet it and the kangaroo jumps up and
puts his claws in the kids fat stomach
yeah uh Skippy is the episode where
Jimmy complains about Qantas exactly I'm
complaining they don't have any Wi-Fi at
Devereaux says what is that and Tony
Bonner Tony Bonner he [ __ ] Ken James is
a good head of hair he's an Australian
boy Gary Frank Hearst was Frank Hertz
I did one called Frank hearts where they
told me there was things hidden in my
heinie
on April Fool's I said Frank hurts look
at the boys shirt yeah he's uh look at
the kangaroo looking off at his [ __ ]
trainer yeah who she was holding up a
whip oh boy or a club cattle prod I'm
sure back then like these animals we're
told what to do with a cattle prod yeah
like a whisper it's just zapping the
whole time if you call this boys stomach
I'm gonna put this on your genitals
again and the kangaroo knows that this
little wet lipstick is getting a [ __ ]
zap too because the fat boys stomach a
mass grave of kangaroos during the
season another Skippy yeah all dead via
severe electrocution to the genitals
I don't know Skippy was a bit of a
douche yeah yeah Skippy be like flipper
hi Dennis like flipper sucked Oh another
episode where flipper jumps out of the
water and does that swim backwards thing
and he gives them like this something
news yeah yeah yeah you gotta help but
Oh we'll follow the other in the boat
can't we're ahead on vacation I'll swim
with the dolphins
I did that Atlantis in the Bahamas I
never did it probably really happy
Islands I think Travis did that too
that's great
he adopted the dolphin - it was
apparently left in a car that was very
hot we actually thought they were signed
up for swim with the orphan why would
you lob these at me yeah what's it
called my chimp yeah
being a monkey we're running around
simple chimp listen oh yeah oh that
woman that has no face that started me
in the chimp oh my god her name what
don't tell me her name was in
Connecticut I figured uh Charlotte Nash
you Charlotte Charlotte a Charlotte me
in the chimp in the chimp yeah that's
terrible
that's the real life me in the chimp
yeah yeah that's what happens yes reg
evidence [ __ ] chip right there it's
better now though we're not being great
if the chimp jumped up just started
eating Greg evigan squalls and clawing
his face and the truck Corrine's into a
family of five took her hat off she's
blind
yeah she's blind he ripped her eyes out
she's got no I gotta sit there and into
the universe for 12 minutes it bit her
fingers off maybe you don't want to miss
me and they couldn't fix she's fixed now
which I wouldn't say fixed but how does
she look now better put a London broil
in the chair and just [ __ ] do that
Tony Soprano
that's disgusting
Charlie Nash 2014 she looked better
she's probably better known oh wow
that's a raft of the face jacket
actually a lot better I mean it's a lot
better but I wouldn't say I wouldn't go
so far as to say fixed holy [ __ ] and
Karen
oh poor lady could she have done because
she has to breathe through her neck I
think Oh how's that working out no I
mean through her mouth the good news is
she doesn't have to blink anymore dude
she could go out she could literally
travel and nobody would stare at her
like that's it that's it that's amazing
Oh Ted know that and know that it was
because yeah that was a poor lady can't
breathe not much emotion going on in
that face though no not at all
Otto should be working her
ah she's still blind though those are
fake eyes no thank you what's that
ripped out her eyes yes that's right
they try to de try to immobilize their
opponent whatever so oh there their
arrival so they'll bite the balls off so
you can't reproduce they bite your
fingers off and they rip your eyes out
chimps are very very nasty yeah
and that's just for starters I'd be so
upset the chimp started attacking me
because you just know it's over Johnny
balls eyes and fingers are all gone they
[ __ ] it what do you protect right yeah
III would probably got a ball
[Laughter]
karate-chopping you gotta protect your
balls but then they gouge in your face
they go for the eyes first oh and you're
just gonna sit there not looking while
he rips your balls oh then you just bite
your fingers off so your eyes wouldn't
have any protection really the [ __ ]
chips are like cartels they really a gun
I got to get organized yeah taking this
bananas on a desk organizer is the best
organization he hangs up the phone hangs
up the phone and like moves our speaker
around then he said he's ready to go to
war with Sosa so wipe him off the map
told not to [ __ ] with you little monkey
teeth all ties back together that's
right
wow that Charla Nash what's Neil
deGrasse Tyson saying about da he's on
seeing that what's he saying about UFOs
he's basically saying look if there's so
many UFOs family the town's bring one of
the bodies into the town square the town
square
yeah just reading into the town square
which one is that what number is that we
don't have it cuz we had to we had to
sacrifice it for Denny's Christmas music
Christmas music Danny I would like to
know what the hell is happening with
these UFOs a lot of people come in to
singing uh there's a lot going on
everything was fake but that looks
pretty real pilot I guess was part of a
documentary about aircraft carriers and
he's you know he's legit and then he
said it was when I saw it it was
otherworldly mmm it was
we can see the color world the color
version rewards we're seeing the
infrared version I think it was pitch
black out it was nighttime nighttime oh
they said it was white okay and they
were tracking it they got it on infrared
they locked it on you could see that he
should have just you know what [ __ ] it
launched - no come on Fox one and just
launch that [ __ ] shoot it down
and then you know you were a guy that
started an interstellar war doesn't have
some kind of [ __ ] you know a shield I
wanted to see how long it's gonna take
him to get to force field I'm not a Star
Trek guy I know that stuff I lost in
space codes oh I'm sure little Jimmy
Robinson oh no money well what's that
Billy Mumy Billy Mumy and a will Robin
daddy
Angela Cartwright Oh No Dennis Balcon
going to be some competition for the
young boy you think you like young will
spare me the poisonous Barb's and play
some ABBA
[Laughter]
we should right yeah wouldn't work yep
Troy do you feel vindicated with all
this UFO talk especially since you kind
of put you attempt it anyway to put Neil
deGrasse in in his place a couple times
lose Neil deGrasse and Neil deGrasse and
sometimes you know we Millennials like
to shorten things that is true that I
mean just we like thrown it's a nice
band maybe when he comes in you could
pay your respect any respects the
Minotaur is I think yeah I think you do
that at the end why would you put a T at
the end of respects
you're like one respect you're talking
into your coffee cup
dan aykroyd is a big believer in all
this yeah that's cool that really is the
guy I go to he is the go to UFO expert
absolutely was like 182 guy link 182 guy
I could see some [ __ ] idiot like that
guy from blink 182 I'm making a lot of
money with the band and then he goes
online one night [ __ ] up stoned
whatever it is since sees some UFO you
zooted thank you chip right and see
something on UFOs and then it's like
yeah I'm gonna dedicate my life to that
now and then he leaves blink yeah yeah
in blink 182 anymore people are hoping
that I [ __ ] find something that I
become passionate about so uh Troy do
you feel vindicated you had Neil
deGrasse Tyson in here
where's bond you were trying to explain
to him that there's all this evidence he
kept talking about the goddamn town
square yeah yeah it's gonna be an
[ __ ] you know I really don't I think
he's kind of a tool to be honest with
you Wow and he's just he just puts up
that stupid [ __ ] about like bringing
the body where's the body
where's Roy he's a scientist and those
guys have no level of proof he's playing
stupid is what he's doing where does he
want you to bring the body he wants to
bring it out so everybody sees it where
there's so much information and finally
this stuff comes out where does he want
the body to be brought what part of the
town town with town square yes right the
town square
I don't think he didn't know though no
course he is no I know Kaku he knows
have you ever seen interviews with him
he knows about you I have Laden's body
what's that my would he yell and bring
out the my body and touch me
here's why I don't think they've been
Laden existed those guys are there's no
it was really killed there's no um those
guys are never they don't what
scientists can't go out on the limb on
that stuff because they don't even
investigate sometimes they'll be left
out of the bit W like the laughingstock
so a lot of times where those guys don't
even pursue it in their business because
they'll be model is that true or is then
the story that where's the story they
want you to hear right now I believe it
I'm sure there's scientist would be like
hey listen wink-wink nudge-nudge this is
what's really going on what a hero he'd
be I'm talking about but he'd also those
people that come out and say stuff like
that are threatening their lifetime the
launch is not being threatened [ __ ] the
ally and your career is fine as long as
they don't harass it look at you let me
see you a gray [ __ ] time to lunch can
do what he wants though because he's
blink-182 so at the end of the day
people are kind of kind of feel what
Anthony feels about him which is like is
this [ __ ] idiot from blink 182 yeah
why should I put any credence in what he
says there's a highborn a discount
though that video is pretty aggressive I
seen it on TV and he goes hey there's
aliens everybody goes yeah he's the
physicist you must be their mother tom
to lodges it's he's doing a cool thing
he's working with the Pentagon if you if
you guys get a second check out him on
Joe what song do they do they don't
economy we're only five sighted we're
not a hexagon rich you don't like that
[ __ ] right I love it it's fun right the
Christmas episode is coming up hmm oh
yes yes
it's a barnburner don't want to give
away any of the twists and turns in that
episode huh it was fun what a sing a lot
of us do it I can't even
that was [ __ ] hilarious [ __ ] some
maniac you had a lot of fun
Lenny Marcus - oh yeah a Jew there on
Christmas yes a lonely Jew yeah like
Stan's the Grinch rich - isn't really
practicing Jew you have a tree in the
house that's nice for a kid and my you
know my wife is an atheist in your house
though are you gonna do I'm an atheist
after the wedding he couldn't resist
there is no God hey these Christmas
trees
Holly is not a religious symbol yes a
holiday tree named Christ
right in the goddamn word we're trying
to call it entry holiday tree it's a
Christmas tree
Trump bringing back Christmas with a
vengeance your honor nobody's alive
Chris no I'm not a visiting [ __ ] yeah
you see Bill O'Reilly tweeting about his
shirt sizes last night
oh did well shorten quotes I'm an
extra-large what was he doing it from a
restaurant in New York on Facebook man
you want another person you won't see
any more
I was selling his books going Oh killing
my career you should put out that book
now is he doing as well as he was now
with his own size
no yeah Bill O'Reilly okay he's laid out
he just he just said like it said
something to the effect
oh here's the tip of the day many
clothing companies have stealthily cut
back on material so order your stuff one
size larger than you are I'm six four to
ten and an exhale used to do it not
anymore
now double XL a lot of people took that
to mean the bill o'reilly doesn't
realize he's could just gotten fat he's
gotten fatter he's sitting at home not
working right just fishing for people to
send them free suits good do you think
but hold on how many of you know what
that [ __ ] last video maybe it's not
what he used to do almost six hundred
and thirty thousand views on a video
that he put up October 30th I'm not
saying the guy doesn't have a following
that's yes maybe he'll get a cable show
are they doing a new network with him
and [ __ ] not steven crowder there's
some new thing they were talk about or
no no CRT what is it CRT is it
conservative something I heard Gavin and
Gavin's on there there yeah yeah they
got a network they got a network on a
star together they stole yeah yeah okay
I didn't even know it's gone I just did
an interview with a Gavin yesterday
where is he based out of New York yeah I
did an interview with him about Saturday
Night Fever as a matter of fact he
brought that up earlier the fact that
it's so racist against Italians and some
guy wrote an article about how terrible
it is and I he asked me you know what do
you think
this at being you know a WAP yeah I as
you are and I'm like I don't care like
most people if they see something like
that they don't give a [ __ ] like I found
it funny that they're sitting around you
know who touches my hair
don't touch my like I find that [ __ ]
funny and yeah it's a well it's
stereotypical no one talks like that now
Yuri [ __ ]
you know all that [ __ ] like no one would
talk like that right I've known some
real [ __ ] guineas that that talk like
that
yeah tip of the day I like a good tip of
the day Oh mouth he does tip of the day
but again he still he does have a
following yeah he doesn't a falling you
don't go a little bigger than he used to
be I don't matter
nine thousand likes not that that's
everything 2600 retweets that's some
that says everybody's making fun of him
are they this tweet went yeah mocking it
went viral funny it did go viral baby
awful eating it any like some retweets
that be [ __ ] embarrassing at least
some people would pay attention waffle
why would you continue to tweet if you
weren't getting likes and retweets
I wouldn't you would know chip gets like
some retweets he does yes he does
based on what just people his humor no
Yuma yomo I hate unpacking dress shirts
out of the package because it's just
like I don't understand why there my
tonnage like that with the pins they're
always pins like brackets in there and
clips now and plastic under the collars
the the cardboard thing and then the
plastic thing in the front I'd rather do
Kramer's X as far as shirts no I've
dedicated my life to figuring out how I
can find a dress shirt that I can wear
without tucking it in there either
easier said than done
he just runs to the there's a company
called on Tekkit thanks thanks I was
gonna play this and I know I was gonna
mix it up a little pitch the commercials
on Fox News all the time and you know